the ability for your business to tackle
the unpredictable
is critical whether tackling unexpected
shifts in supply chains
or surges in customer demand at the core
you need a database that can back your
business
power next-gen applications and leaves
all of the management to somebody else
without breaking the bank so you don't
have to worry about quick shifts any
longer
we demand a lot of our databases and our
databases demand a lot of us
your database can be a powerful engine
or
a management headache traditionally
databases tend to be fragile
expensive and tough to maintain without
one that can scale without limits
provide data consistency
and eliminate management overhead you're
faced with
an inability to scale with new business
needs data inconsistencies that can risk
losing your customers trust
and cost inefficiencies since it teams
are tied up maintaining those systems
instead of innovating
your developers wind up implementing
their own complicated database sharding
or partitioning strategy which leads to
over provisioning resources and
ballooning costs
not to mention the cost of managing
backups scheduling maintenance windows
meeting performance requirements and
securing the entire thing
you end up having to pick between scale
consistency
or management free you can't have it all
until we created google cloud spanner a
fully managed
relational database service that scales
horizontally
is strongly consistent and speaks sql
spanner offers an industry-leading
99.999
availability with automatic software
updates and instance optimizations
you get zero downtime yes zero
and no maintenance windows it's used to
power workloads large
and small from applications for just a
few to
massive apps with global users spanner
is simple to use and manage
so you can build applications that
transform your business
while lowering your total cost of
ownership tco
let me show you how first off spanner
offers scale
for relational databases significant
effort is required to grow a cluster
horizontally
to support additional capacity and
setting up data replication in different
parts of the world
has never been easy you're left with an
extremely complex architecture requiring
a specialized team to maintain
with spanner you don't need to shard or
replicate data
nor build intricate frameworks to scale
up quickly it
vastly simplifies your architecture and
operations
because it automatically distributes
data and automatically handles replicas
sharding and transaction processing
across
regions and continents so you can
quickly scale to meet any usage pattern
deliver data closest to your end users
with the lowest possible latency
and ensure success of your products with
a single click or api call
you can start with small workloads and
scale with no limits
choosing spanner means you won't need to
rewrite your applications
or migrate databases even as future data
volume grows
this brings me to my next point
consistency
traditional databases force users to
choose between performance and
consistency with eventual consistency
you risk serving stale data to customers
which might not be acceptable in
time-sensitive situations like
retail finance and gaming for example
showing an item
in stock online when in reality it may
be zero
this can lead to a bad customer
experience and loss of trust
spanner uses true time which leverages a
fully redundant system of atomic clocks
that means spanner applies a time stamp
based on a globally agreed upon clock to
every transaction on commit transactions
in different regions are executed
sequentially
no ifs ands or buts on the commit
timestamp
and finally high availability spanner
offers up to an
industry-leading 99.999 availability
so you're protected from failures how
spanner provides high availability via
synchronous replication between replicas
in
independent zones it uses a paxos-based
replication scheme
in which rights are committed only when
a majority quorum is achieved
you can choose between regional and
multi-regional replicas that span
continents across the globe
unlike typical database services spanner
does not need
any maintenance windows or downtime
spanner also
offers online schema changes meaning
easy schema updates
no downtime no disruption for your users
spanner is enterprise proven secure and
battle tested at google
with features like manage backup and
restore and open source
emulator for local testing a variety of
client libraries
and performance tuning tools you can
achieve business continuity
lower development costs and empower your
developers to get started
right away meanwhile data layer
encryption
iam integration for access and controls
and comprehensive audit logging
give you enterprise grade security
spanner has been used in industries like
gaming for user profiles and real-time
play data
fintech for account data and ledgers
healthcare for medical records and
patient data
retail for supply chain and inventory
management
tech for real-time decision making and
performance data
and media for digital rights management
and catalog metadata
spanner is the enterprise database
giving you the best of relational and
non-relational features
with transactional consistency sql
support
automatic sharding and replication and
nearly unlimited scale
cost effectively streamline your it
operations
give your end users the experience they
demand give yourself
peace of mind through its reliability
and build
transformative applications at the speed
of your business
try it out for yourself by going to
cloud.google.com
spanner and stay tuned to hear more
about spanner
[Music]